all right guys
bang bang i've got a treat for you today
in that i have for the first time ever
three different people who are
all on together we'll call this a
virtual panel uh
or just a hangout session whatever you
prefer
uh but it's all about stable coins and
so maybe we can just kind of go around
the horn here
adam will start with you then we'll go
the congressman and then to caitlin
and just give a quick introduction as to
who you are and
kind of what you're working on today
great thanks mom my name is adam
trademan
i'm the ceo of vrd we are a global
bitcoin wallet
about 5 million customers also provide
software for
enterprises that are looking to
accelerate blockchain tech
i'm currently based in tokyo actually
ceo three companies
i also work on behalf of a large
japanese investment bank
svi here in tokyo and i've been in the
bitcoin industry since about 2015
time frame seeing a lot of ups and downs
it's been a wild ride
and happy to be here today to discuss
stable points with you
i'm congressman warren davidson i'm a
republican member of congress from ohio
i'm a member of the house financial
services committee so we oversee
you know everything in this space uh
that that would be a security uh but
then you have commodities and oddly
enough in congress that's broken off
into the ag committee
and then when you look at things that
would be like utility tokens this would
be
something that's broken into energy
commerce when you look at that
you see just straight away some of the
dysfunction of congress
so if i thought congress was working
great i probably would be back in the
private sector or still be in the
private sector
and would not have stepped away from the
businesses that i had at the time
to come into here but it's been exciting
time my time in congress has really been
concurrent with you know the ico market
and everything else but frankly
my big lift here is to try to get
members of congress to understand the
technology
and frankly to understand the
implications of it so we get a
regulatory framework
that keeps america the innovation hub of
the world for this great technology
and hey pomp kaitlyn long uh ceo and
founder of
avanti bank uh literally just finished
the wyoming blockchain select committee
we are we're in the middle of a two-day
meeting just finished uh
day one i think we're actually going to
be doing something interesting on
identity i think we're actually finally
going to break through on that so
i'm wearing my wyoming brown and gold
today bleeding up
writing for the brand and uh we also
just kicked off wyo hackathon today so
it's
it's a big day this is a wonderful way
to cap it off
thanks for having us absolutely uh
congressman
let's start with you uh one of the
things that you and i have talked about
in previous episodes it's just what is
money and why that
is important and so uh you've got a uh a
unique view for many that
of your peers but uh one that i tend to
agree with can you just talk a little
bit about a stable coin is really a
digital representation of
money or a currency and kind of let's
just start with like what is a currency
or what is money in your opinion
yeah so if you look at um you know the
idea of money
uh in america we think of it as dollars
inherently but
you know it's been you know a
phenomenon in human civilization for a
really long time
and it has really characteristics that
make it a store of value
and a means of exchange so it's really a
tool
to facilitate a trade that you know two
or more parties want to uh want to do
so when you think about trying to make
it digital uh it's really taking what
we've done in paper
uh which evolved from you know carrying
literal goods and doing a trade that way
and the node a banknote was really a
representation of
what you had stored you know with that
bank
now we do that with paper and it
represents a store of value and if we do
it digitally it's
essentially maybe the easiest way to
think of it as a block of
data in a spreadsheet and you you could
have say hey i own this block
in an excel spreadsheet but it's a store
of value and a means of exchange
and the way it does that in the most
efficient way would make it a more
useful type of money
absolutely and caitlin maybe you can
give us an overview of just
where stable coins uh kind of have come
in uh in the western hemisphere and then
adam will come to you and kind of talk
about asia but
um caitlin just where are we with stable
coins today
uh you know kind of really throughout
north america
sure um it's been said that stable coins
are the killer app of blockchain and
indeed uh
right now i think that is actually
proving to be the case
they're they're just alternative payment
systems they're alternative settlement
systems but they solve
a couple of very interesting problems
with the legacy payment system one
of which is it just takes a long time to
settle payments that's especially true
in foreign exchange
but uh it's also true in domestic
payments and the other is the settlement
finality issue
that uh most folks uh most folks are
under uh
are aware that uh credit and debit card
payments can be so-called clawed back
which means they can be reversed
but ach payments can be as well and
uh for up to as many as 90 days
it's technically um 60 days plus the
statement period but if at the beginning
of the statement period then it's really
90 days
and that's an acute issue in digital
assets and so i think this whole
settlement finality
topic wasn't really in the vernacular
until the digital asset
issue came out or industry came along
and then all of a sudden you've got a
huge counterparty risk on your
transactions if
a digital asset dealer can uh
will deliver you a digital asset but you
can claw back the dollar payment that
you sent them
that's a huge risk issue it's true for
everybody it's not just for the digital
asset industry but for
obvious reasons it's particularly acute
for digital assets
and that's in that's in part with stable
coins we're designed to solve
i do have to say though that it's ironic
the original use of stable coins is
different than what it is today
and that was because wells fargo took
bigfoot it was a bitfinex's bank account
away
and and essentially the the traditional
us banks wouldn't serve
the digital asset industry and so uh um
uh invention is the mother of necessity
in the digital asset industry created a
way to get us dollars and it solved
this additional problem which is really
now the raison d'etre for
stable coins that's awesome and adam
maybe give us an overview of kind of
where stable coins are
in uh japan and greater asia yeah
and i was just gonna add i think um
congressman davidson and caitlyn bring
up good points right and that is that
the reason why stable coins could be uh
sort of the killer app here is because
they combine the best of both worlds
right when bitcoin was created
it was created to have better properties
of money than
than current money at its time and those
properties of money are things like
fungibility
divisibility transportability right and
with a stable coin you get the benefit
of something that is non-volatile right
or limited volatility which has always
been the complaint
against bitcoin guys like warren buffett
and other respected investors right
but you also get all those other
benefits that bitcoin was originally
created to have right
transportability you can send it over
the speed of light anywhere in the world
nearly instantly right and fast
settlement like caitlin said as well
right so stable coins offer sort of the
the best of both worlds and they do so
most importantly i think
in an environment that fuels and is now
being more
compliant and is accepted by regulators
and that's critical because
we operate not the wild wild west but we
operate in the real world and the real
world
you have to follow the rules in order to
build businesses right in order to solve
people's problems
in a way that's going to scale in asia i
think that what we find here
not just in japan and you know i i think
in the 80s
everything oh japan is the future and
all these great things right but today
you know the we all know that the
country that is driving
a lot of growth and innovation is china
and and we see a lot we feel a lot
both by proximity to china here in japan
but also by
you know nationalistic pride frankly in
the sense of competition
and you know i i think i'd be really
interested to hear what
um what congressman davidson and um
caitlyn think about this as well but i
think modern wars are fought with
economics
and i think that you know superpowers of
tomorrow or even of today like
china are embracing new technologies
and recognizing these things and are
looking at them as ways to flex their
power and their muscle
and to get an advantage especially you
know in in the current situation that we
have with the global trade war and
whatnot as well
and so i think that we in america need
to be very conscious of that
and very much like we fund our military
and our traditional sort of instruments
of defense and
and um and protection that we need to
look at economics in a similar fashion
and we need to evolve and change more
quickly because
i think that's how countries like china
look at it they think in decades they
think in centuries
they don't think in weeks months or even
in years right and so
you see the transformation to the
digital rmb which is essentially
a um you know state issued a stable coin
and um it's not that it's something
that's going to happen over a decade
it's the kind of thing that a country
like china can implement in a year
if they can get rid of coronavirus or
kova 19 you know in three to four months
you know they can they can replace their
entire physical cash economy
you know within within a period of time
not much longer than that and so we
really need to
be aware of that and we need to see and
understand how they're going to leverage
that against us and you know we need to
stay competitive
absolutely uh congressman davidson maybe
we can talk a little bit just about
the conversation for yourself and your
colleagues uh there's obviously been
uh talks of a digital dollar or stable
coin
kind of how are people thinking about
that internally i think we saw
a clause in one of the stimulus packages
where that was kind of an idea
is that something that you think is um
possible in the short term is that
something that
you know is kind of a dream and we may
not see for five or ten years
kind of just how do you look at the u.s
dollar
being turned into one of these digital
dollars and kind of being controlled and
issued by the u.s government
yeah so great question you know the
person who held the seat i have now
in congress before me was speaker
boehner and
you know obviously was in the seat for a
long time before he has a saying
you know things happen in congress very
slowly until they happen very fast
and and i think that's the way uh right
now it feels like good grief man
you can't even get people to speak about
this in detail
and frankly the number of people who
truly understand it right now
small but when you get the right bit of
momentum it tends to just fly
through sometimes sometimes with way too
little scrutiny or dialogue
so that's the concern um right now
because
you know if you look at the federal
reserve they had originally said that
they were going to
stay hands off and faster payments and
so banks and
fintech companies dumped lots of capital
in there they poured all kinds of r
d and developed all kinds of products in
the faster payments arena
and then once that looked ripe and
robust the fed just said
yeah we're going to play in that field
you know so essentially
uh i don't think that's right we're
still trying to um
you know deal with that in congress and
and um i think the same thing could
happen here with the
their view of digital dollars versus
what congress's view is and
generally congress doesn't assert itself
very well
they got it right when they were
developing you know when the internet
was developing congress didn't drive
that but they put a legal framework in
that made it work well
and in this case if we don't act i
really feel like the
the risk is that we're going to get a
digital dollar that's
essentially like the digital r d which
gives the government
the ability to intervene on any
transaction
uh you know all the characteristics that
bitcoin has
of a truly distributed ledger with no
central authority
um no intermediary it is really a
good replication of cash right so if i
have a 20
bill and you and i agree on something
that you know we trade the cash for
the service or good and the transaction
is completed we don't need permission
from someone else
and and so you know to me a currency
is clearly more valuable when we don't
need the third party to do that
but for some in government they want
those features to me that's an
authoritarian style system
and it has you know when we use lingo
like uh you know bitcoin versus [ __ ]
coin
uh as a differentiator one of the key
characteristics between the two
is whether there's a central authority
that can destroy
destroy or distort the value of it or
frankly block um transactions
and and for some in congress that's a
feature that they want
right they want it to and that's
inherently incompatible with a true
distributed ledger technology
and it goes to custody issues you want a
third party to verify
the custody or things like that and well
that's part of the feature that's why
it's faster that's why you can
can do these things and so if you try to
build those things in
uh to a central bank digital currency
it really doesn't work the best way that
the technology does
and and so as you're trying to explain
this to colleagues who
in my opinion are drawing the exact
wrong conclusions from the bank secrecy
act any money laundering know your
customer
provisions that guide the current
banking framework
which is essentially to say we need
bigger more powerful
you know tools and more government um
it it's distorting the whole it's
complete economic distortion of the
purpose and utility of money and so
we to me before we can go live on the
central bank digital currency that would
work
right and really give the united states
of america
a comparative advantage with china is we
should get a system that plays to our
free and open society
which could be like true distributed
ledger technology
so hopefully that's clear to people that
understand some of these terms
but you know part of this is to give a
good piece of education for people that
are still kind of learning the lingo
absolutely no and i think those are
really really important pieces because
uh it's one thing just to implement
technology but if you uh if you do it in
kind of a nefarious way or a malicious
way
uh kind of ruins the whole point of this
so i think that's a really important
point
caitlyn maybe talk a little bit about um
if we do get kind of
the right uh type of stable coin issued
whether that comes from
uh kind of the private sector or from
the uh the central banks
how does this interface with the legacy
financial system
and kind of banking organizations and
really just from a thought process of
uh does it change what they do um or is
this merely just
the same type of fiat currency in a new
technology form factor and so they
update some technology and then it's
business as usual
oh no it's majorly different technology
as you know that's part of the reason
why
the enterprise blockchain efforts didn't
generally take off they've succeeded in
niches
but you know five years ago everybody
thought enterprise blockchain was going
to completely
rip out and replace the you know legacy
systems of the
financial world and i even subscribed to
that in at least in the beginning
because i think it should
but that didn't mean that it would and
the reason is because
they're two fundamentally different
architectures uh there's a
um that the architectures of of the
legacy financial institutions use
centralized systems that duplicate data
and then across the parties and then
everybody has to reconcile
well distributed ledgers use
decentralized systems
and nobody has to reconcile because
they're shared by everyone but they're
heavily encrypted
whereas inside the big financial
institutions pretty much nothing's
encrypted even the small financial
institutions
they just have really strong firewalls
and nothing's encrypted on the inside
um you know bitcoin has no firewall and
everything's encrypted right so
they're just really fundamentally
different architectures and so how do
you actually have
the uh the legacy financial institutions
even if the central bank were to
um uh and again i'm talking about the us
although this is true in much of the
developed world there's just
legacy infrastructure that's just
fundamentally incompatible with the with
the it architecture
of distributed ledgers there's another
piece of this that's uh that'll be this
will be a u.s specific comment
which is that there is there are very
small number of
core service providers in banking
software
and they do not have the capability to
do
to to to integrate with wallets and so
um i think it's years away because
the the technology has it's just
fundamentally different
and i could go into a whole different uh
discussion about the impact of the fact
that all the banks in the in
the u.s rely on a very small number of
of software providers and only a few of
the very largest banks are exempted
from the requirement to use one of those
software providers well what do you
think happened over the last you know
15 20 years to those software providers
who were
comfortably in a in sconced in a
regulatory advantage position
they didn't they didn't keep up with uh
with modern software practices let's put
it that way
in fact um some of the hottest fintech
companies are are
you know trying to break in to that um
you know
effective monopoly uh but if you think
if you understand that they're not using
modern software practices and this is
part of the reason for the attribute of
the payment system
and here comes this distributed ledger
stuff which is all wallet based
these are two fundamentally in
incompatible
i.t architectures and and uh it it
literally
has to be built from scratch and and do
you integrate it back with those old
systems that's
that building that middleware to
integrate it back in and of itself would
be a massive task
that's why i i i when i left the
enterprise side of the business i
realized the public blockchains were
where the action was going to be
and we're just building a parallel
financial system that is entirely based
on these new art architectures
and what we want to try to do is just
build bridges back and forth between the
two
but but the two are going to be
coexisting and
they're not really existing i think
within the same
legal entities for that reason yeah
that's a very good point
adam maybe talk a little bit about uh is
it possible
for the central bank digital currencies
to be built by the governments you
talked a little bit about china
obviously
kind of what they've done uh or are we
gonna have to see kind of public private
partnerships in your opinion around the
world
uh in order to actually get the uh the
digital currencies uh built correctly
gosh you know i i couldn't agree more
with caitlin's comments i think that the
technology is so fundamentally different
you know spending like uh most of my
career in silicon valley
you know and um pitching vcs and all
this about disruption disruption
disruption
you know they say disruption uh really
occurs when
the old system becomes irrelevant not
that it becomes improved it becomes
irrelevant
right and that's like going from you
know cds to
mp3s and ipods and things of that sort
right and and i think those
sort of paradigm shifts unfortunately we
can learn from them
when we talk about money and banking and
finance but we can't mirror that and the
reason is
like what's just said they have to
coexist for some time because there's
inertia
in banking there are bigger companies
and governments even who have a lot to
lose through this transformation
and it's not just about money it's
control and it's power right
and so there's got to be sort of a more
of a compromise
really right it can't be one of these
disruptive silicon valley-esque
apple comes in and decimates the you
know music industry
and just replaces it with something new
because it's better
and cheaper for the end user right the
customer right in this case
it's it's got to sort of have you know
the the oversight
and the the buy-off um or the uh the
sign-off
of of governments and that's why um you
know folks like a congressman here have
such hard jobs rights to figure out what
that compromise is
and to figure out sort of how to get um
everything agreed when disparate parties
have such big differences in
expectations
whether it's a chinese style um you know
police state
uh you know all the way down to a
democratic you know entity like
the united states of america so i think
that in china
um you know they can they're
authoritarian um
it's they are clearly like what they did
with covet 19
they literally just close the roads i
mean they can do whatever the hell they
want
and they have a population that is
willing to accept that actually and
they're very patriotic about it
i actually admire that about china right
the people just they they just go with
what's said and
and they you know rah-rah-rah right at
least that's what we hear
right that's what we hear so you know i
think in in the u.s it's going to be a
combination
of technology providers and it's um and
sort of government
um oversight of those companies i think
that to caitlin's point all these core
banking providers it's not just in the
u.s it's in europe it's in japan it's in
other places a small number of really
old backwards companies
who frankly have been you know no
disrespect but
you know comfortable dumb fat and happy
as they say right with these big
monopolistic style contracts
and you know okay you know we understand
so there's got to be some change
it's going to take the regulators
opening things up a little bit
and that's a slow change in order for
these new technology companies to be
able to come in
and by the way this is the same thing we
see in the private sector
all the time right like with ibm and
then microsoft came in and kind of ate
their lunch right and then google came
in and ate their lunch and there's a
long tail on ibm they're still selling
computers believe it or not
you know who they're selling them to all
the big banks who use all those old
computers right
there's a long tail on microsoft there's
a long tail on google right so the tails
keep getting longer
and there's going to be a long tail on
on the traditional financial products
and software as well
the bottom line is this this is how i
think because i'm building a consumer
and an enterprise but really a consumer
business and that is what are the what
do the customers want
right what do they want you know i used
to be able to go to my bank and get five
percent interest i get squat now
i'm working my butt off you know for my
salary i'm putting it into a bank and i
trust the bank
but you know i'm not getting anything
for that now i'm hearing about these
yield you know bearing interest bearing
high yield accounts i'm hearing about
all these
opportunities for yield farming and all
these you know things where i can get
not just three or five percent but if
i'm going to take a little bit more risk
by the way my money's literally sitting
like the equivalent of a wells fargo
right i mean there's
zero chance i'm gonna get anything there
right and i could take a little bit more
risk
with some of that discretionary income
that i would otherwise invest
um in things like oil by the way which
obviously you know
more volatile than bitcoin recently and
um you know as a consumer i like that i
want to provide for my family i want to
turn my savings into more money i used
to be able to do that i can't do that
anymore
so if the consumers push for this stuff
that's why i think the occ changed their
their rules recently
right is i hope it's because the
american people
and as a proxy the banks lobbied the occ
to enable this to build new business
around what customers want
right and in other countries uh there's
just
a lot more flexibility in a lot of cases
to do that right and so i i hope we can
we can embrace things
um in the u.s like they have in these
other jurisdictions as well
that's a great perspective uh
congressman davidson one of the things
that
adam kind of hinted at was uh this
almost competition right between
china who has very grand ambitions
they've been very public about
kind of wanting to get their digital uh
currency out and into the hands of
consumers um i think that in the last
conversation euna had on the podcast
they may have grander ambitions than
just uh their own citizens using this
and then kind of
see an opportunity to get globally um
access
to to really kind of drive adoption of
this uh the us
obviously at some point i think our
belief is like they'll wake up to this
and say hey we should do this as well
um talk a little bit just how you see uh
the relationship with china the
competition the kind of economic
trade war we're engaged in right now and
how the stable coins or
central bank digital currencies kind of
plays into all of this
yeah so it's a china in particular is a
good area for me to
kind of illustrate how i even get
involved in this so
you know when i graduated high school i
enlisted in the army
cuban army ranger went to west point
came back as an officer
did all these things in the military and
then in that sense you think of
china as a potential uh you know
conflict right you think well maybe i'll
never even go to china
under friendly conditions and so when i
get out of the army i get involved in
manufacturing
and manufacturing in the 2000s has
inherently involved trade with china
and you experience all this friction of
trade so
you know back when uh you know you're
looking at
uh you know you know digicash
and early early ideas in this you start
going oh well maybe there's a solution
to digitize money so that you know you
could actually
get past all the intermediaries and just
get the goods shipped
so you would miscommunicate with all
this stuff
and it really shows like you know the
governments sometimes just like the
architectures get in the way of people
who just want to work together
so you can build great relationships
with uh you know people
all over the world that's been my
experience and um
and and the hope is that we have the
kind of government that lets
that happen uh you know at the nation
state level
china is uh clearly got a different
vision of how to run their country
and and and how to run you know not just
not just uh you know their overall
country but how they would go about a
digital
currency so you know just like uh
you know they can do things well you
don't hear a lot of dissent out of china
because they can you know just put you
in jail or
you know create a million uh you know
million plus weakers to put into
concentration camps and re-educate them
we certainly hope that the united states
of america doesn't try to replicate any
of those things
but um when you think about it the a lot
of the push in capitalism and capital
markets in the united states
is to take our capital markets and
frankly deputize or
partially nationalize the banks or the
publicly traded companies to say
you know tell us everything about your
customers you know
um and you know the fourth amendment it
does not say
uh the fourth amendment is the right to
privacy and it does not say that if you
have nothing to hide well then you have
nothing to fear
right it says you have a right to
privacy not secrecy
not no way for the government to find
out anything
um and we have an ability to take
advantage of our cultural differences
and do essentially what what you know a
feature of bitcoin is a layer of privacy
not true secrecy um but that's being
eroded in the united states because
of at the edges the only way to get into
the on-ramp easily
is is essentially you know entities like
coinbase that
to come to work in the united states of
america
uh and and build you know get a return
on their capital that they're innovating
and putting at risk
they have to comply with know your
customer uh bsa
aml well finance doesn't have to do that
they're doing all kinds of things
you wonder why it's scaling so
differently on the back end in china
they're looking at this stuff in a
different way
they know way more about the identity of
their people
and they do it to a point where they're
building
uh social credit scores so literally in
china's system
they could know all the stuff in the
world about every customer that comes in
on um a transaction
particularly with a central bank digital
currency and you know in the united
states we have credit scores
we don't really have social credit
scores and in a way that's kind of what
some people in the united states are
pushing for is
well you know you're not going to bank
those people are you you're not going to
you're not going to
you know we made it legal that for
example we made it legal that you can
transact marijuana or medicinal
marijuana in some states
but you're trying to use the financial
system to essentially
uh still keep it illegal even though
that debate
on the upfront was having you're
leveraging money to try to distort law
enforcement
and or you're leveraging publicly traded
companies so that's the real tension
that exists and so when adam's talking
about
you know the legacy system that
tension's real i mean these people
whether it's a government institution
like fencing or treasury
or you know the occ um
[Music]
adapting to the reality we have to say
are we gonna
basically take the shortcut easy route
which china's taking
and it's the easiest morph off of where
we're at is to say we're going to have
central authorities with all the same
data collection points
that china has only we're going to work
to do it better right
or we could say we're going to have a
free and open society
that respects some layer of privacy with
the ability to get a warrant
and find out solve crimes but we're not
going to turn money into a weapon
and you know frankly in a way the odds
are stacked against that working just
like the odds were stacked against our
founding fathers
trading this country that did protect
those rights
yeah i couldn't agree more i think that
is a fantastic way to
view it caitlyn any thoughts on that
well sure i mean there's an inherent
tension between um
between privacy and um use of the
internet
and um you know i think the the privacy
advocates in the u.s
lost that battle in 1977 when the bank
secrecy act was
put into place in the first place it's
been substantially expanded and
just last weekend with the buzzfeed leak
about all the suspicious activity
reports which are
it's a felony to leak those but somebody
did and
uh boy there was a lot of information
granted most of it was pretty old
but uh but it's just that you know
i think was rahm emanuel who said never
let a crisis go to waste that's going to
be viewed as a crisis
in that world and the magnitude of
compliance is actually going to be
ratcheted up
further or compliance restrictions and
the sad thing about that
is that that actually puts even more
compliance costs on the small community
banks and
essentially just um it makes it such
that the only ones who can
service those customers and handle all
those compliance which is an
enormous amount of work and cost
are the very large banks and so people
get the opposite of what they want
they don't they don't want the big banks
getting bigger but um but it's the
regulatory mandate especially on the
compliance side
that um that's that's uh that's
difficult
one other piece about the regula
regulation going back to this whole
question of can they
can the u.s implement this even if those
in congress who are proposing um a
digital dollar
for the distribution of so-called
helicopter money and it just came up
again today i think there was another
bill proposed today
could could it could it happen and the
answer is
none of the regulators are ready for
this they do not have there are
basically three things that have to
happen in order for that kind of
regulation to get put in place you've
got to pass the law first
and then the rules have to be
implemented and then the bank regulators
have to have a supervisory manual so
they can determine how to examine the
ones that are actually handling this
that is a years long process in wyoming
we're 27 months into it and
just about to i understand released the
supervisory manual on how bank
supervisors can supervise banks
activities in digital assets it's the
first one that's ever been drafted is
1500 pages long
promontory consulted on it
and i'm sure it will be you know heavily
copied
by other regulators around the world um
including the occ national bank
regulator here in the us and other
states as well
um but up until now it didn't exist you
can't just
you know pass a law and suddenly those
things actually come into being it it
takes a long time and the us
is building the consensus for that the
digital dollar
foundation for example is working
towards that but it's not something
that's going to happen quickly
and one other piece of that related back
to the privacy and
technology uh neil ferguson has made a
couple of really interesting points
about the national security implications
of losing the payment technology war and
i i i think he's right um that that
that uh that that you won't keep your
reserve currency the reserve currency
yes sure it's the it's the perceived
stability of the issuer
but it's also who's got the best payment
technology
and the world's going to migrate to the
best payment technologies i've said this
before
multiple s p 500 companies have been
using bitcoin quietly
in the uh you know mostly in emerging
markets where there are not
well-developed
banking systems because it's the best
technology they'll never tell you that
publicly they will never be in the
newspaper about it
but it's been happening for years and uh
and so they
you know they've got the best incentive
to go out and use
use whatever technology they need and
they're going to go find it and if the
u.s really does lose that race
then it's our own fault i
i love hearing that go ahead adam i was
just going to say you know
listening to this it makes me thankful
that we have folks like
the congressman here fighting the the
good fight you know to
um to defend those principles on which
america was founded frankly right and to
not
become a police state like uh some of
the other large countries in the world
that we've been discussing
um but i i you know i i'm really curious
to get your folks opinion on this
sort of call it a solution let me let me
paint you a picture and i
i've talked about this before um
privately maybe not publicly and that is
that is the following so first of all
like let's talk about bubbles like all
the you know crypto folks like pomp and
i you know we love to say
stuff like hey you know what's the
biggest bubble in the world bitcoin
isn't the biggest bubble the biggest
bubbles the us dollar right
the us dollar is a self-sustaining
bubble supported by the us government
used to be backed by gold and under fdr
you know we said well we ran out of gold
okay we're just going to back it
ourselves by
well whatever we're backing it right and
and so it's a bubble but that's not a
bad thing
okay because within a bubble if it's
self-sustaining and it keeps growing
it becomes something like the us dollar
which is the world reserve currency
okay which is damn impressive right now
what the congressman said before
is that on the fringes of crypto we have
to play by the traditional fiat based
rules
if we want to onboard through coinbase
we have to go through the kyc process
and all that
but imagine this this world for a second
imagine
you are being paid your salary in crypto
and then you're holding all of your
crypto yourself in
a decentralized wallet in a wallet like
what caitlyn was talking about before
right and then you're paying all your
bills in crypto
you're paying your mortgage you're
paying your credit card bill you're
doing everything that way right
and your whole world is within crypto
you never have to go back again
and better yet you never have to come in
because you're within the bubble now
that represents a possible future
where the rules that cryptocurrencies
like bitcoin were created on
can be truly realized even within the
context of the otherwise fully regulated
you know world that we live in i don't
know you know i mean
you could you could do what um vietnam
did and just make cryptocurrency illegal
a government could do that and that's a
way to stymie that
that whole vision you know instantly and
to be very honest with you when i raised
money for
for my company back in 2015 my would-be
investors asked me adam what's the
number one risk for your company and i
said oh it's very obvious the us
government says bitcoin's illegal
because if they do that you know all
bets are off everything's gone
right and frankly i've been shocked by
how forthcoming and
and supportive um us and other
governments have been
actually in helping foster the growth of
crypto related companies
but if we can create a new bubble within
crypto
and transact all within that bubble that
to me represents the kernel
that could become the snowball that
continues to grow that really transforms
money
and i you know honestly believe can make
the world a better place by
doing a lot of those things that that
others mentioned right and realize the
benefits of
you know quick instant settlement
international trade and things of that
sort
adam this is why i enjoyed talking to
you because i uh my question to end this
was going to be what is the
future world that you hope to see or
kind of paint that picture which you
you just expertly did uh maybe we'll go
to congress
congressman davidson and uh any kind of
reactions to uh to that world that was
painted there
yeah i mean i think that's a an
interesting vision but the reality is
most people hold their wealth in
something else and in the united states
while the u.s dollar still is the
world's reserve
currency i mean i recently founded the
sound money caucus
because you're actively seeing the
dollar destroyed
right so this year we've printed four
trillion dollars now it shows up as debt
right uh but it's not really debt uh
debt means you borrowed it there was a
lender there's not a lender here
it was just printed right so inherently
that undermines the value that would be
the exact
case for sound money that you you've got
a known quantity
there which is why people look at some
things more like gold or digital gold or
backed currencies things like that so
the principles of sound money i think
are
are going to drive uh the exit out of
the current us dollar because
of dynamics like caitlin was talking
about but the other part is
you know we're in a world where many
countries are pushing negative interest
rates
we've seen that pressure in the united
states we've seen the federal reserve
talk about
rates out you know at holding the rates
essentially zero until 2023 the treasury
yield is less than one percent
i mean that's a nominal positive number
but no one believes that represents the
real return
you know adjusted for inflation that's
already a negative return
so if you hold us dollars they're being
destroyed that's the whole micro
strategy play
is i'm gonna keep my treasury which in
their case was fairly large
instead of watching it be destroyed i'm
just going to hold it in something that
has a better store of value
but still more liquid than gold which is
bitcoin in their case
right so i think that the pressure for
negative interest rates and the
massive amount of debt that the united
states has means that there is going to
be a huge push to exit into something
maybe this bubble that adam's talking
about
and and i think it highlights how the
sense of urgency
that we should be working with to get
this arc built
to get everybody to safety because um
you know otherwise you know
it's really you know how painful of a
chapter 11 do you want to go through
but it's coming and we're going to have
to be ready to deal with it and
you know central bank digital currencies
could be a good way as long as we can do
them
uh without too much central authority we
we do it to protect people
instead of to control them
absolutely
what's so fascinating about the
bankruptcy point you just made
congressman
is is is looking at how tethers actually
used
um even when when it was acknowledged
that tether wasn't wasn't fully backed
by us dollars
it's still after dipping down it traded
back up
close to par even though everyone knew
that it wasn't fully backed
what was really going on look at look at
the velocity of
of all those stable coins i did a a
a table back in around june 1st and the
velocity of the three big us dollar
stable coins tether
and usdc and paxtos was
all in the range of 45 to 55 times that
means
that on an annualized basis each one of
them trades 45 to 55 times the velocity
of the us dollar by the way has
collapsed it's 3.8 times right
so you're looking at at a just order of
magnitude different velocity
because these things are viewed as hot
potatoes and the good news is they
settle really fast with settlement
finality
but the other good news is you don't
need to hold on to them very long well
the other piece of this is as you all
know that stable coins have exploded
this summer in um in both issuance
as well as in velocity the velocity is
accelerated
and i just updated that table a couple
weeks ago using coinmetrics data this is
on-chain verifiable velocity so none of
the you know exchange reported stuff
which of course is even higher
but um that velocity range was 45 to 55
times
it's now 64 to 154 times
so the velocities just exploded and and
again i you know tether
is to me such a fascinating case because
even when it was acknowledged it wasn't
100 backed what it was really valued for
was the payment system
not for the solvency because people
could literally treat it like a hot
potato
and then move out of it uh as fast as
they could and
ultimately that's the value that payment
systems really are are designed to
uh to to make and i must credit uh nick
carter for saying
if the us actually goes down this path
of
allowing us dollar you know bank money
then then frankly it actually extends
the life of
of the dollar as a reserve currency uh
but if if the us loses that technology
war um
and doesn't do that and we stick with
these really clunky old
multi-day payment systems that don't
have settlement finality and even with
fed wire
when you're trying to use high use out
for high value payments you can't time
the precise
timing of the closing of those of those
payments so you
you nothing's programmable about it at
all
and whereas all this programmable money
is is cropping up around the world
if we don't if we don't as a as a
country move in that direction
and and and start encouraging some of
these technologies
then uh then we do move further behind
i'm i'm optimistic for a couple of
reasons
though because you're starting to see
the fintech companies acquire bank
charters it used to be that fintech
companies software companies never
wanted to be banks
um but i think everybody's realizing
that you've got to marry the software
with the bank
you've got in other words the banks are
the ones that clear the the payments
directly at the fed
and so if the software company isn't the
bank
then those are two separate processes
and you never get the maximum value of
the software because it's all still
settling on those old clunky rails
um if you if a software company becomes
the bank now now all of a sudden you get
uh you get uh real competition in
payment systems so watch
square gico vero there they've all
recently acquired bank charters it took
square three years to get theirs
but um but um this is not an
insignificant movement and it's
it's reason to be optimistic i love that
as we go to finish up uh i want to give
each of you kind of a last word so maybe
adam we'll start with you go to caitlin
and then
the congressman to uh to finish it out
but any any kind of final thoughts when
it comes to some of the stuff we talked
about tonight
yeah i just want to say that you know i
think this year has been
really troubling and difficult obvious
for obvious reasons for everyone
around the world but you know i i think
one of the
uh silver linings on this this cloud
that is still over
all of us is that it's caused people to
really um
you know self-introspect about their
lives and about their families
and about their finances the things that
are very important to them and
there's been a huge huge uptick in
cryptocurrency as a result of that
people have been learning
the google search results for bitcoin
and buy bitcoin and crypto and app store
searches
everything is way up all of the metrics
for wallets or
all-time highs and all of that and and
the reason is is very simple it's
because
people are asking themselves the
difficult questions they finally have
some time
they're sheltering in place they're at
home they're looking at what they can do
to protect their wealth and their
families in the future
and they are seeing that these kind of
technologies whether it's a bitcoin or
stablecoin or
or one of these alternative assets that
is digital can really impact their lives
positively and to me as an industry you
know
executive and someone who who joined the
industry coming from a completely
different area
but did so because he wants to to figure
out a way to
to to bring some good into this world i
see that traction that consumers find
the value in this
as the most inspirational thing going on
in the industry right now and that
growth
and you know consumer sentiment is
always gonna
um you know companies are gonna move
slower than that
right and it's gonna take time for them
to catch up and and especially when
there's inertia you know in banks and
governments and things of that sort
um but you know we might just look back
on this someday and say the kova 19 was
the catalyst that really helped
kick off a lot of the digitization
whether it comes in a stimulus bill or
it doesn't i think the
the ice snowballs already started
growing
and i think you know once it's big
enough which it is getting there i don't
think it's
going to be stoppable so i'm really
excited about it never been more excited
for the industry
awesome caitlyn yes
i would refer to a piece that that dr
monwan singh and i
co-wrote that uh was just published in
the ft a couple weeks ago about the
programmability of money
and and and and what is so important
about programmability and why you need a
blockchain
you can't you can't just use
programmability with
with a traditional relational sql type
database
because the blockchain gives you
consensus it allows you it allows all
the parties to share the infrastructure
not to have to duplicate and replicate
and reconcile the data
and and that's what a blockchain version
of a programmable dollar
offers you that a traditional it
architecture does not and that's a
really powerful concept
and literally the velocity of these
things has been proven out it's not just
unique to tether it's it's the others as
well
and the implications of that for
monetary policy are pretty profound
we have to congressman davidson's point
it really expanded the fed's balance
sheet in an effort to try to get gdp
growth well if you think back to your
economics class
one of the variables in gdp growth is
the velocity of money
well we now actually have programmable
money that isn't itself
extruding exhibiting very high velocity
we don't have to do it through issuing
more debt we can do it through
technology
and that's something that makes
everybody a lot better off but we've
actually got to
break through the barriers and get it
started
that's a great point congressman
davidson bring us home
any uh any last final thoughts yeah i
think it's important to um
you know just understand where we're at
you know i think adam did a great job of
recognizing some of the you know
friction in terms of moving to where we
really the technology makes possible to
go
and frankly i think where consumers want
to go uh
and so you know you may see uh you know
a less optimal path for a while and
you know it's just a it's such a
critical time to get right because
it really is going to have a profound
impact on the nature
of our culture in our life as to whether
this
tool uh sound money is a means of
control
or a means of freedom and i use
typically you can't defend freedom if
you don't defend sound money
and those principles are so important
and they're playing out really in a
different way not on the money side
but in securities law so if you look at
the sec
uh with with you know the ico market
and the the lack of will
to define a bright line test to say
we're going to say something's not a
security
as long as it meets this criteria and
frankly at some levels is not as
important
what those criteria are as the fact that
they're certain
so that capital can come to work in the
united states of america
one of the fears that i have is as we
continue to dally
on this is the capital even though we
have silicon valley
we have venture all over the coast tech
all over america and now wyoming you
know
doing great ohio doing great with this
great innovation
uh on on all of the gazillion potential
applications in blockchain
uh the capital is going offshore not to
avoid our laws but to find regulatory
certainty in places that have
taken the time to put frameworks in
place and so
i just hope i can get my colleagues
either educated enough
or i guess pliable enough to say you
know i don't really understand this but
i know these people do
and and let us get a good framework
because
it really is vital to get that right so
that the innovation in capital goes to
work in our economy
and it goes to work under our principles
versus china's principles because it
really is
a truly meaningful difference i think
that is the
absolute best way to end this so uh for
those that are
listening or watching uh this was a
herculean effort because
uh myself and congressman davidson are
on the east coast caitlyn's on the west
coast then adam is in uh
in japan there so we we found time to
line everybody up and
i appreciate all three of you uh taking
the time to do this i hope that people
really learned something
uh today and we'll have to do it again
in the future
thanks bob thank you very much
appreciate it
thank you all it's great spending time
with you hopefully we can do it live
somewhere sometime
yeah hopefully so thank you